Another direct challenge is Pull,
automating the retrieval of data.
So far we've only discuss the fax
machine replacement-use case where Dr.
Johnson sends a patient chart to Dr.
Jones when he refers Marla to her.
Suppose Dr. Jones wants
information from Dr. Johnson.
Suppose Marla has started recording
her blood glucose readings at home and
Dr. Johnson wants to retrieve the most
recent ones to see how she's doing.
Suppose Marla has established a personal
health record and wants it automatically
updated whenever there's new information
in any of her medical records.
These are all examples of Pull,
where the recipient,
not the sender, initiates the message.
Accomplishing this is
still in the future, but
a group of experts have proposed how
it might be done, as shown here.
Using some new standards within
Direct for requesting information and
sending back a response.
This would be done using
specially formatted XML documents,
similar to constructs that already
exist in quality reporting and
that we'll see in lesson eight.
Another interesting aspect of this
proposal that's not specifically limited
to Direct is that all of
the patient's data would be stored
in a repository that would receive and
respond to these requests,
presumably based on each patient's
information sharing preferences.
Many people propose something like this
to simplify the privacy issues we'll
discuss in lesson four.